what's one word each of you would use to
describe season two of euphoria chaotic
complex are we allowed to curse i'll say
funny it's funnier
how you doing now i know that fans have
been waiting two long years for this
next season but so have you guys zendaya
how excited are you to bring people back
into this world that you all created i
mean i mean we're incredibly excited i
mean i guess
excitement and nervousness and you know
there's a lot of emotions that are
attached to this i think because this
show unlike anything else so personal we
live with it for such a long time we
have an entire crew of people who
dedicate every single day to making
hopefully a beautiful piece of art that
resonates with people i'm definitely
proud of the work we've all done and i'm
proud of
how far all these characters have come
as soon as i saw her i was just
immediately afraid to lose her hunter
take me back to that first day back on
set this is it what was the vibe like i
mean did y'all just pick up where you
left off yeah i think we were all just
uh really like at that point after all
the delays and uh everything uh just
really craving to get back to work and
it is like a family in a lot of ways and
i think we missed like our you know
that's good that's kind of like our home
it was kind of scary honestly it was
like was it like coming to this because
we'd been away for so long for me it was
frightening because i hadn't you know
i've been at home for a really long time
you know i can't even speak like that
anymore can i move like that but then it
very quickly became familiar and um you
know it was the same old story which is
the best it was home you're like a
relationship kind of girl right you guys
can all judge me if you want but i do
not care i have never ever been happier
you guys know better than anybody that
fans have been waiting a long time for
this second season in fact i feel like
they are already dissecting so many
trailers so many promos they're piecing
things together they already know things
are about to go down with maddie and
cassie sydney what do you want to tell
fans about that friendship and how it
shifts this season well i don't want to
give too much away because it's quite an
experience and a roller coaster for them
there is some wreckage there's
definitely wreckage and we waited also
two years to be able to give you guys
the show so like we were anxious as well
so we're so excited that it's finally
it's finally gonna be out there for
everyone alexa how much fun was it for
you to play to this showdown if you will
between maddie and cassie very fun
the showdowns were
i mean very in the moment extremely
intense and like not fun but of course
when you
after the fact you think about what you
just shot and you're like oh that's
gonna be that's gonna be fun to watch
why do you look like that like what like
a country music in a good way or a bad
way [ __ ] you better be joking mod oh my
gosh you know sydney had said she wanted
to share more scenes with you this
season what was it like for the both of
you to explore that sister dynamic it
was so fun i think like
we're like best friends so we had so
much fun
shooting together and yeah i think i
mean there's so many things that are
explored this season that weren't the
first season and i think your dynamic is
a lot more complicated than you would
expect so i was actually saddened to see
how complicated it became as this went
on because i was like no sam i want to
keep working with mod more and more
seeing what the sisters did to each
other started to
sort of break me i've always been with
you
from before you were born
do a good job of showing how tight you
all are i mean that chemistry and that
bond that you guys have really
translates on screen have you felt like
that relationship has also evolved the
one between you and zendaya yeah
absolutely i mean that's my big sister
nobody can tell me any different it's
just a blessing to be able to become
close with and and experience someone
who you've looked up to for your entire
life and she's really in my corner those
are the things that matter being on a
show with her is really cool but like
her being a cool human and a supportive
human is even cooler how's your new
years going it's
new year's
new year i swear my boyfriend doesn't
tell me anything
[Music]